human sacrifice dogs and cats living
together mass hysteria there's no time
[Music]
13 o clock alright here we are we're
back again it's Tuesday and it's episode
117 yeah here's no it's another one of
the lore of our paranormal shows people
people get excited when we do godparent
well it's not really it's more like
psychological sickness yeah mystery yeah
type stuff so this was actually a
recommendation and it's a damn good one
cuz I don't think I would have thought
to do this on my own
yeah there's obscure yeah I mean
obviously we did a show on the Salem
witch trials and I think we talked a
little bit about quote-unquote mass
hysteria back then but someone I believe
it was actually even on that episode
like on the YouTube video we're like why
don't you guys should do a whole show
about mass hysteria is like throughout
history like dancing plagues and stuff
like that and I'm like wow that's a
fantastic idea so I started like
researching because I wanted kind of a
good mix of different cases to cover and
stuff like that and I kind of went down
a rabbit hole where I was just like
writing about all these different
reading about all these different cases
and reading about like the reasons for
it and stuff like that and really um the
causes of it are mostly unknown and it's
kind of like a hard thing to diagnose
because it's almost kind of like a last
resort diagnosis it's sort of like well
all these people are acting in this
particular way or showing these
particular symptoms and we can't find an
organic cause for it so therefore it's
probably a case of mass hysteria but you
know a lot of sociologists and
psychologists have pointed out that well
that doesn't preclude the possibility
that there might actually be an organic
cause for it like say a pesticide or
food poisoning or some like that but we
just didn't find it so we're just
calling it
of mass hysteria yeah and some of this
stuff is ongoing now it's almost kind of
like current event because right now in
Africa they got people thinking that
you're stealing their penis well that's
some [ __ ] I'm dick thieves no well
that's actually a thing it's a thing
yeah originate there it's actually a
whole syndrome it's in the dsm-v
whatever it's called the diagnostic
manual and everything it's called Koro
and I'm gonna actually talk about this
that is actually kind of fascinating
we're gonna get it some of that is
culture-bound syndrome they used to call
it that because most of the earlier
cases were from China but since then you
know it's kind of spread worldwide dick
yeah so that's yeah that's kind of an
interesting thing but like I said before
I said well I'm gonna save that to last
because like it's doubly not funny for
the people that it affects cuz it is an
actual psychological distress guys
getting killed over it
there are India there are it's very sad
and it just goes to show that this
I mean taken to an extreme it can be
actually quite dangerous because when
you stir up fear of that type I mean
people are gonna get hurt and it does
happen like that it's like some [ __ ] out
of the medieval era where they're gonna
which panics and stuff like yeah so like
I said you know we're not gonna talk
about the Salem witch trials cuz we
already did a whole episode on that you
know but that's a similar type of thing
that we're talking about but there's a
ton and a lot of other ones that are
having and are still happening in the
present day so we're gonna get a little
bit into that before that we'll just do
a couple of shout outs at the beginning
like we usually do if you haven't seen
our latest movie retrospective it was
the Stuart Gordon film castle freak kind
of a kind of a lesser-known Stuart
Gordon film but it's actually a pretty
good one if you want to check it out
also our last matinee which came out on
Sunday was what Suspiria Bohemian
Rhapsody and The Nutcracker
yeah don't worry about Nutcracker C
believe me it was good so much you know
I didn't understand superior she
understood it you know - that's kind of
my she's a brainiac she saw the original
- I didn't know it was about witches I
talked I talked about it in the little
room I said this is way as soon as I
realized it was about witches I was like
okay is little bit more interested see I
thought you knew because
I thought that I had shown you the
originalist no I never seen it but I was
going I was getting kind of bored that
first 20 minutes of what is this about
yeah then I saw what they could do it I
wasn't oh yeah okay you'll see I guess
because he can he figured like the
director figured that everybody had seen
the original and it was about witches so
he didn't like really do anything it's
like yeah they're witches cuz everybody
knows that like I said I thought
everybody audiobook we ran into some
difficulties we had it all pre-recorded
and recording quality really didn't
didn't I couldn't get it to adhere to
the a see understand education which if
you've ever recorded or uploaded an
audio book are quite stringent yeah
they're getting better they weren't
quite a stringent I don't think before
no they were they were okay um but you
know for some reason I just kind of got
them but this one I was driving around
on and then a couple of the I found out
later when I was going to edit some of
the some of the chapters that I had
recorded I got this really terrible
unbelievable like crackling sound to my
kind like through the whole thing so I
was like I think it was some kind of
data problem yeah and it's like yeah I
think it was a big issue yeah cuz each
little cut was going above an hour and a
half because a mother kind of like
pixellating again I've heard that some
people have had that issue with this
particular Yeti microphone that if you
know if you have other programs running
or if you don't have enough RAM or you
have other things going then it's gonna
start crackling after a certain point so
I got that on a few and I said you know
what I'm just going to we built another
little studio in the closet like yeah in
that closet I got totally insulated with
huge covers it's got to be like a
hundred degrees in there and she's in
there reading the book with the cat
trying to get in there you don't fight
the door to get in you guys watch a baby
cookie she's I guess I killed still call
her kitten even though you know one and
a half but um she has to be like up in
your [ __ ] all the time like hey mama
what you doing hey daddy what you do
it's like you know she tries to jump in
the dryer she was warning me she's in
there she's in the claws I know she's
like what he's in the glass yeah
that's telling me you gotta let me in
this is Jenny to the closet yeah so it's
hilarious
she's like charged so sometimes I'm
trying to read and I can hear a little
cloud she's like in there trying to eat
the microphone yeah it's like you know
but that ivory recorded like half of it
it sounds a lot better it's a lot better
it's gonna it's a much better product
yeah and honestly um the way that I've
recorded it this time like I'm trying to
be really careful and just like record
things in just little segments so I
don't have to like rework little minute
30 minutes two hours
chunk right over again because honestly
I've read this yes do that once she's
read this book three four times out loud
and I'm like really sick it's like I
probably haven't memorized it this yeah
but um but yes so the fact that I'm
recording it better to start with I mean
hopefully will mean at the back end it's
like less editing I still take out like
I said all the burping and stuff like
that yeah and coughing fits and yeah
yeah nothing is is once this is done
we're gonna re we're gonna repackage all
her fixation yeah and that's gonna come
out maybe one or two audiobooks cuz it
isn't out on audio and that's gonna be
an awesome like a one-stop-shop for
people who want to hear yeah I'm right
and like I said I think we mentioned
this we have to repackage it to make it
more martica marketable because she was
doing that stuff before audiobook was a
thing so yeah yeah so we're gonna we're
gonna make it into a more modern product
and then we're gonna go back and we're a
problem we're gonna rerecord to higher
standard the other audiobooks probably
starting with faceless film in an unseen
hand
yeah faces villain one yeah and then on
scene I mean this sound all not when
it's okay but I think it could be better
and we could probably we're gonna and
then we're probably the mayor of books
do those yeah eventually we're gonna
totally reboot mammoth mountain because
more stuff is happened since then more
can be added to that story yeah we
wanted to do and we're not gonna yeah in
the second edition I think it doesn't
have to be as dry and scholarly cuz at
the time that was that was your first
nonfiction paranormal war so it was kind
of like we were trying to make a
statement of that this case really
happened you know I mean yeah and with
the market actually was a
parapsychologists first right we're
gonna make it more it's still gonna be
true it's still gonna be like that but
we're gonna add more detail and make it
a little bit more novelized slightly I
think it might be better you think yeah
it might be a more fun read because it's
a little dry yeah a little dry don't had
people tell me that they thought that
made it scarier well maybe we'll maybe
we can I'll keep both editions well yeah
I'm not gonna get rid of the first yeah
I just wanted to do a second one liked
it because I have we had some more [ __ ]
to add and it's like you know we wanted
to kind of expand it out a little bit
because it's I mean it's a little short
so I kind of wanted to add some more
stuff and I can tell what happened to
red you know cuz Uncle Michael red died
yeah and maybe we can do some more
interviews with Louis that might yeah we
can do more updates and like dates
remind us more of stuff that had
happened during that time yeah and there
was you know there were a few details
that we left out for legal purposes and
[ __ ] like that that maybe we can put in
yeah true yeah cuz some I was like
worried about it I never really done
enough I've done a nonfiction book
before and there was some stuff it's
like I changed those names and I changed
the names of location and we also so I
wouldn't get my ass in trouble and we
also abbreviated oh I think we
abbreviated one aspect about another
family that was briefly involved with it
at the time yeah I think we kind of left
that out to kind of cover our asses on a
legal thing - yeah okay but we'll see
what we can do with that yeah cuz I
can't really afford a lawyer so camera
ensued over yeah but so I definitely
wanted to like keep so we had a safe
room after me right good some of the
people involved are so uh that that case
has some fans I mean you know if you
read the the reviews on there there's
some people you know like one cop was
really freaked out by that story but
yeah there's more to that story doesn't
change it a whole lot but there's some
more detail that we kind of had to leave
out well I'm like you said so much so
much happened that you probably forgot
yes it's hard to keep a lot of it
straight about the order in which
certain things happen so the way we
wrote that webby wrote that
we kept we wrote down what we absolutely
knew happened in what order yeah there
was some other stuff that happens is
that we'll just leave that out yeah cuz
it was kind of like this you know hand
towels moving yeah basically so so much
of Yankee pit that you didn't know which
happened on what yeah right because it
was just like yeah and The Skeptical get
in there and try to pick all that [ __ ]
apart well you said that it happened on
this day would have man it was it was
chaos for a week yeah well yeah and [ __ ]
man I don't even know I don't even
remember what I [ __ ] ate yesterday
yeah much cosmic hob I don't even
remember 1982 cops will have a big
shootout with a bunch of criminals and
then afterwards they try to give a
report and they can't keep it straight
well you and everybody knows that the
shootout happened were you gonna go into
whether this shoot I didn't happen
because they got their orders wrong
memory
really especially under stress is not
under like an Exeter like a situation
you don't ignore every day I mean it's
once you get over the shock you're gonna
be able to remember it that well this is
the way the human brain works it's no
you know no joke you remember what
happened but you don't remember the
exact order what happened first right
you know you know we talked about on the
you know we're talking about memory and
stuff like rocks like it's it's
unreliable that's just the way the
memory is it sucks but yeah thanks I
wish Webb was still around because
remember all that good stuff that he was
remembering yeah you remembered about
the hot wheel cars yeah you didn't even
yeah when he when he mentioned it oh
yeah put that one in the book I go we'll
put that in the book that is in the book
because I talked to him on the phone
didn't yes it talks in their phone and
he remembered it before I wrote it so
because like I said I got statements
from them too like when retinol alive
okay but yeah all right so let's kind of
get into the main topic talking about
mass hysteria now mass hysteria it
should be noted is not it's kind of like
the casual term but it's not actually
the legit medical term it's actually not
really a legit it's not like in the
diagnostic thing for the psychology
things it's just like I said it's sort
of like the
you know kind of the symptom blur the
diagnosis of last resort when they can't
think of anything else that could be
causing this particular thing but
generally when they talk about it it's
most usually called mass psychogenic
illness or MPI so they don't really call
it mass hysteria more because hysteria
kind of has a negative connotation
you know saying that Oh women be crazy
you know what I mean
so essentially because that word comes
from uterus so you know so that was like
the implication that [ __ ] be crazy
tonight I like it like I'm gonna bring
that [ __ ] back [ __ ] be crazy how do
you say it again
well what is it with the word hysteria
his day okay hysteria okay yeah because
like I said it's based on the the word
for uterus I didn't realize that that
was like I said yeah because you know
the whole wandering womb thing and it's
like oh the women and their wigs and
wandered around it's like history I hate
histrionic Personality Disorder
crazy-ass [ __ ] because you say you're
gonna bring it back dude it never was
yeah where people still think that yeah
you said you said hysteria from some
reason I thought it I thought you said
miss Kaja nation or them it for some
reason I don't know doesn't have
anything my mind was wandering somewhere
else when you said it so I get your
might see wandering kubu colouring brain
wonderful yeah water break cuckoo card
it's going right down into your but I
was actually you know those duh where
was it going I was actually having a
mini flashback about [ __ ] Mammoth
Mountain okay oh man I can't believe
that [ __ ] happen that was [ __ ]
awesome
yeah looking back on it as I know very
lucky to see that well yeah so like I
said mass hysteria I know people use the
term very loosely meaning like Oh
anytime a bunch of people just go
apeshit that's not really what it is
it's usually when a group of people
start displaying usually physical
symptoms with no organic cause or no or
cause that they can locate that's not
always the case sometimes it's kind of
like a media fueled panic
much like the Satanic panic which we
also did a show about the clown
sightings that happened in 2016 which
I'm going to talk about in a little bit
more depth later on you know the mad
gasser of Mattoon which we also did a
show about like Spring Heeled Jack where
you know one incident kind of Spurs this
panic or like you know an anxiety in a
kind of closed in community that this is
happening more frequently than it's
actually happening so those are like two
different aspects of it now the
interesting thing if you go to the
Wikipedia page for mass psychogenic
illness it will tell you like what are
the sort of parameters by which they
judge something is mass hysteria like I
said it's usually what's that
psychogenic that's what I thought you
said that yeah it was based on that was
the world
okay now hysteria hysteria yeah used to
like as as soon as a woman like stood up
about some and say hey I don't like this
[ __ ] they're like well to the mental
hospital with you lady yeah that was a
weird thing that I did back in those
days they just locked it Locka Locka
Locka woman up but in the old days they
slammed in a convent and then you know
after that they said oh we can't put him
in a convent ymore Snell just what was
the way they walking about [ __ ] that
[ __ ] we don't like that's bruising what
was the real motive what is it that they
were talking about they didn't like what
were they saying I mean it was different
in every situation but it was usually
women that you know were unhappy with
their you know status in life or it was
you know women that acted different than
they were supposed to you know we're
eccentric or other things of that kind
of nature they just weren't acting as
they were expected to so there yeah I've
seen the ruins of those places that you
know the guy's exploring them like
deservin explores this places were huge
yeah they were huge they were filled up
with women yeah any interesting thing
that's kind of like related to what
we're talking about because a lot of
these outbreaks did take place like in
nunneries and stuff like that where a
lot of the women there were put there
you know against their will for various
reasons
and it was very Chloe stored it was very
conservative was very repressive and
they didn't have a lot of avenues for
expressing their feelings are acting out
or like talking about you know what was
bothering them so you know so a lot of
times it would kind of manifest as these
kind of crazy you know not crazy in a
bad way but these kind of like weird you
know mass hysteria is like there was one
in France where above like one nun
started meowing and then like a bunch of
the other ones did it you know it it
almost kind of was like a safe way to
express that something was wrong because
they weren't really allowed to in any
other Avenue so it's like well maybe if
we just start acting and I don't they're
not doing it deliberately they're not
doing it consciously it's just anxiety
and stress and it's kind of like coming
out in this weird psychogenic sort of
way so that's something that
sociologists have looked into is kind of
a cause for this because it should be
noted that even that women actually are
a little more disproportionately likely
to be affected by this kind of thing
they're like it's not a huge thing
because you know the dancing plagues and
things like that that also affected men
the Cora thing also affected men so it's
not just like a woman only [ __ ] be
crazy thing they said it's usually has
something to do with stresses in the
environment it happens a lot during
times of war and times of plague
you know people from low socio-economic
you know backgrounds people who feel
like they don't have a lot of control
over their life or what's going on so
it's a way of acting it's like a
pressure release but yet like you said
it's kind of like the poltergeist thing
right yeah one of our theories about
that it's a similar type of thing but
it's just causing physical symptoms
rather than you know the paranormal so
you know but I think it's kind of like
the same sound so it sounds reasonable
yeah yeah so usually what a what an
outbreak of mass hysteria would
generally look like like I said it's you
know it's something where they can't
find an organic basis for it there's no
you know there's no food poisoning
there's no poison gas there's no nothing
like that
the symptoms tend to be sort of
transient or you know ones that are sort
of generalized most common ones are like
headache nausea fainting things like
that some of them are weirder like I
said like dancing until you pass out or
have a heart attack things like that
nature of meowing but generally they're
pretty standard you know stomach aches
diarrhea that types that type of thing
wonder wonder if there's a link with
Tourette you know what's weird is there
was actually I can't remember where it
was white now might have been might have
been
Laroy in New York that I'm thinking of
but there was actually a mass hysteria
outbreak like in a girl's school where a
bunch of girls started displaying
Tourette's like syndrome started
twitching and they started like because
one guy and this is back in the 1800s
and 1900s I think was early 1900 to
observe some poltergeist activity
thought that maybe it was linked to
Tourette's and we and what's funny is
that you know sometimes I talk to venom
and [ __ ] maybe that's like Tourette's -
yeah it may be I mean that might be a
related some kind of outburst because
your voluntary outbursts yeah and I'd
actually kind of like to say this
because I think this is kind of wyman
it's gotten better a lot of good called
it talking to venom reacting to
something that's not very like a
Wolverine walking around just mad yeah
something I want to say to you like I
said I think it's a lot better now than
it used to be because I think back in
the old days and there's still this
really weird dichotomy between people
thinking that the that there's like a
thing between mental health and physical
health you know what I mean and it's
almost like mental health isn't taken as
seriously like shit's like all in your
head and stuff and it happens in mass
hysteria cases too where it's like
people get defensive and mad when
they're like well it's mass hysteria so
you know essentially it's all in your
head but the thing is your thoughts your
brain effects your body your brain is a
part of your body so that you know
sociologists people that diagnose this
type of thing it's like we're not saying
you're imagining it because the symptoms
are real it's just that there's no
external cause for it really other than
your reaction to your situation whether
you're very stressed or something like
that
they're like obviously
can be stressed out and they break out
in hives you know things like that so
it's not you know I I don't want to
think you know anybody think that I'm
coming across this angle it's like oh
[ __ ] Saul in their heads and stuff like
that I mean you know maybe there's not
like a you know there's no poison or
anything like that but the symptoms that
you're experiencing are real symptoms
just the fact that they can't find like
an outside cause for it you know what I
mean that's when that's basically when
they make this diagnose yeah the power
of the mind you can't underestimate it
right exactly I mean that's even in the
animal kingdom you put an animal under
enough stress it it dies yeah there's
nothing physically wrong with it just it
wills itself to death yeah so it does
happen like the moon has a huge huge
amount on a huge effect on your physical
body because it's like I said
essentially it's the same thing your
brain is not separate it's in there you
know I mean and the things you think
about and the culture you grow up in and
things like that affects how you know
[ __ ] that comes out in your body so yeah
but yeah and that's something that they
kind of talk about a lot on this too um
another thing that tends to they're like
in a lot of these sort of situations
it's usually kind of a small group of
people you just like in a school or in a
factory people that can see each other
so you know so if one person starts
fainting or something like that say it's
more likely for someone else to you know
things like that like I said it usually
starts out with older people or higher
status people and then moves on down the
chain although the most the most
commonly P common pert type of person
that's affected it's usually kids or
adolescents when it happens among adults
it's you know usually more women but not
always but yeah so there's that type of
thing now there was there used to be
kind of a misconception that it happened
more frequently among people with
neuroticism like higher scores of
neuroticism or low IQs or higher
extraversion but this is apparently not
the case it was the case and it's a few
scattered you know cases
it happening but in general they're like
under the right circumstances pretty
much anyone is you know vulnerable to
this so it's not like oh it's just dumb
people or oh it's just you know they're
like under a particular set of
circumstances my parents dumb people are
mentally tougher and physically tougher
they're like sharks I've seen it I've
seen their first hand dunk I could just
[ __ ] bulldoze his way through
anything because they're not thinking
about yeah think about it yeah and
they're having fun when another person
might be suffering I wonder too if that
might be why women are affected a little
bit more not only because they tend to I
mean in in cases where it happened in
like girls schools or in factories where
women worked they're like almost
overwhelmingly it was when the women
were under great deal of stress like
they worked very long hours they had
children at home that they were the sole
caretakers for they were the sole
breadwinners for their family they
didn't have any rights they didn't have
any you know regressed of what's the
word I'm looking for any recourse that's
what I'm looking for any of recourse to
like you know have any of their problems
managed so that's kind of what happened
so they were under a lot more stress in
that particularly and didn't really have
a voice or didn't have any way of you
know again of it any other way
and also I wonder too if it's because
women in general not all of them
obviously but women in general tend to
think about things more they tend to be
more empathetic towards other people
they tend to overthink things sometimes
or think about a whole bunch of things
at once I mean the great philosopher
Arthur scopin Hauer says don't do that
if you want to survive don't think about
because the more you think about it the
more you realize everything's hopeless
that's hard he in bed the philosophy
called pessimism scope and Howard bethe
scope there was a lot a lot of scope and
I was true I read your scope an hour I'm
going like yeah yeah he's right but
don't focus on that if you focus on [ __ ]
too much that becomes your reality yeah
I mean whatever you focus on is your
reality well focus on the negative
aspects that's all you're gonna see yeah
that's well that's definitely the guess
you can't I mean what what your
gets on that's you're just gonna see
more effects you're not gonna notice
it's kind of the ignorance is bliss type
thing though as long as you have fun it
just goes through did alright yeah you
got right up to the moment you die yeah
it doesn't matter cuz member I told you
the other day and I don't remember if I
mentioned this on the show or if I just
said it to you but I said you know I I
didn't come up with this but I saw
somebody on the internet somewhere that
compared in general the female brain to
having like a hundred tabs open like on
the internet like it once and you keep
like screeching minute I'm like yeah
that's pretty accurate
and I was just like and every time I
finish one thing I can just close that
tab and then I have 99 more tabs that I
still have to you yeah I tell you don't
worry about it that's it I know but
that's hard she has all these projects
Gowanus is now just one at a time it's
really really hard time don't worry
about it's really hard for me to do that
cuz like I said I have a hundred tabs
open at all I have a hard time open and
one that said a dude's brain is like a
sledgehammer yeah as a female brain is
more like a Swiss Army in general I do
have it easier in a certain way yeah
yeah you do I definitely think yeah not
not in always but in a lot of ways you
do yeah and like I said other
sociologists said that about mass
hysteria to you that it's like in a lot
of situations where it happened and it
was largely women then it happened to it
was in situations where the women were
like super really [ __ ] on you know what
I mean
yeah and they didn't have any other way
of getting out their stress so let's
kind of talk about a few examples of
this type of [ __ ] now probably one of
the more famous ones and well wasn't one
it was like several and it happened over
hundreds of years were the dancing
manias of the Middle Ages now there were
a [ __ ] ton of these like in in you know
it was probably three four hundred year
period didn't Bosch paint these yes I
thought so
yeah bunch of women dancing and you know
things on their heads and stuff yeah
crazy [ __ ] yeah so what ended up having
like I said I don't want focused too
much on just one of them because there
were a lot but what this would
B is that there would be people not all
of them were like this but there would
be like a group of people in a village
they would either live there or they
would come there from somewhere else and
would start dancing and then other
people would join them and they would
just dance and dance and dance so
Burning Man until yeah but until they
pretty either dropped dead right heart
attacks or exhaustion or whatever or
started breaking bones or games like
that nature they would just dance almost
like they had no control yeah over their
bodies weird so this was so common that
there was obvious there was a name for
it
Paracelsus actually had a name for it
you know so they called it curio mania
I guess they called it and then later it
was called st. vitus's dance or st.
John's dance because at first it was
thought that it was some kind of curse
put upon you by a Saint Vitus or Saint
John the Baptist that just like would
make you dance until you drop dead now
there was one that happened you know
there were some like in the 7th century
I think that was the earliest one and
actually there was one before that that
happened in 1020 or thereabouts and I
believe that happened in Germany people
witness to this um well like I said a
lot of different writers have written
about them I know it's kind of hard to
say like from the Middle Ages because
you know amazing [ __ ] up but if you know
if other contemporary sources name the
same thing and it was just one person
writing from another book yeah but
essentially I think there were several
contemporary writers that mentioned it
that were like not related to one
another or you know what I mean so there
were a whole bunch of them like I said a
lot of them in Germany some happened in
England there was the Netherland stuff
like that very large one took place in
1374 and then kind of spread outwards
this happened and I believe it started
in Aachen so they we just just stand out
of town and dance until they died or
couldn't dancing yeah sometimes yeah so
it was just like hours days weeks they
would just keep doing it and then
sometimes more people would join them
what was the explanation for the time a
curse yeah at the time in the Middle
Ages yeah the people dancing what would
they say they believed it was a curse -
I'm not really
sure they said now a lot of them did
kind of happen around like the feast of
Saint Vitus and stuff like that so it
might have been it might have started
out as kind of like a religious
pilgrimage type thing and they were just
like maybe kind of expressing that that
through dance and then other people
joined in because one thing that a bunch
of these dancing plagues had was that a
lot of times the people that were
dancing like if people in the town like
didn't want to participate then the
dancers would get really pissed off at
them would start like beating their
asses and stuff there was also some
weird kind of things where they didn't
like particular colors like they didn't
like the color red in one case or they
didn't like so they saw that colors and
they would start beating that person up
so in other words you have like a rock
concert style environment and a synergy
built up in this mass hysteria they
start forcing people to dance with them
yeah and picking certain people out of
the crowd because just on vague [ __ ] oh
that he's wearing red kill him that type
of deal yeah and it almost becomes like
that like a - oh sure like a feedback
loop and I think that might have been
you know and once a couple of them
happened then they they're stuck in
their music their mind that this is the
thing this is the thing it could happen
and then that's kind of what happened
now one of the ones that's kind of like
a bigger better known when it even has
its own Wikipedia page happened in
Strasbourg in 1518 and this one is
started by one woman evidently her name
was frowned Trofeo and she just suddenly
one day for shits and giggles started
dancing in the middle of the street of a
village four days later she had had 33
other people joining her it almost
sounds like it's almost sounds like
animal group behavior like a flock of
birds maybe thinking it was kind of out
of the road
so kind of throwback yeah maybe in DNA
and it's not really normal for humans
but it's something that maybe can be
activated through maybe like some kind
of extreme pressures in the environment
yeah like they may have been society may
have been so bad that there
a lot of people that were extremely
unhappy and didn't know why it even died
one of them a they don't even know that
they were unhappy because it was normal
to be in that right because like it
better
ignorance and poverty and weird they
were play he only said the times and
dying left and right society wasn't
rational they had a bunch of weird
religious beliefs and a bunch of weird
folk lore that all conflicted with human
nature so it's a way of [ __ ] going
insane yeah kind of leaning toward them
they start destroying themselves because
they're machines that don't work a human
is a living machine in many ways imagine
if you built built robots alright and
then started programming the robots with
corrupted programs they might do weird
stuff yeah of course they do and I think
that's exactly what happened I'm not you
know a computer my functions when it has
bad stuff in it and that maybe that's
what it was I mean the human brain is
amazing and generally pretty resilient
but if you expose it to negative stimuli
enough from all different directions and
and then a bunch of a bunch of
conundrums and a bunch of what do you
call it
contradictions inside of its thinking
system then yeah and that's not-- like I
said because any ones would do that yeah
mass mental illness yes basically
because and the thing about the dancing
plagues too is that a lot of times if
this was indeed if it started out as
kind of like a religious observance that
kind of just went wildly out of control
you know dancing particularly dancing to
particularly exhaustion as you will know
if you've ever been to a rave or
anything like that does cause a sort of
like ecstasy yeah and it's also notable
that these a lot of these happens like I
said when things are very oppressive a
lot of the Middle Ages you know if there
were plagues there was wine might be a
substitute for fighting they can't fight
the authorities so they just start
dancing it is still it's something
something they can do it you know that
was all they could do because they
couldn't fight yeah I think that might
be a really big I mean also religious
all the social and religious you know I
mean pressure on them to behave a
certain way they just malfunctioned they
couldn't fight and burn the cities down
and overthrow Kings and [ __ ] like that
or or tear the church down they couldn't
do that right so they just dance
themselves they felt like that was your
only recourse that they know my sin
inside and I think that that's probably
a really big cause of this type of thing
because it does tend to happen in times
of extreme anxiety or like I said among
people who feel like they don't have any
power or control over their own life
well they had a bad Church and the
church is telling them what to do it was
totalitarian you couldn't overthrow it
because they believed that they would go
to hell yes contradictory yes there's no
way out there's no way out that's
probably what isn't it they had not only
then not only to have their minds
captured that their souls captured in
the afterlife so they were it's a way of
rebelling against their own slavery and
maybe this particular they couldn't kill
themselves suicide would send you to
hell right so this is a way yeah that's
a good point
yeah I mean it may be like I said
perhaps this one that happened in
Strasbourg in 1518 which started from
one woman as far as they know and then a
month later it was 400 people all of
whom were dancing some of whom dropped
dead from heart attacks because of the
exhaustion because they just went and
went to went and didn't stop um you know
that might be a thing where one woman
just was like [ __ ] this and she's
glitched out yeah and then a bunch of
other people said yeah that's that's a
good just all started glitching out
because they saw oh that's a possibility
now that's a way I'm feeling it now I'm
feeling it now
yeah it's it what what you're talking
about is a riot yeah but it's it's a
weird way of executing a riot because
they were so twisted into a not so much
you know I mean they were their minds
were twisted so much with a bunch of
rules that they couldn't riot couldn't
overthrow things they couldn't do this
in that so they just glitched out and it
should be noted too that some of the
dancing manias it wasn't just dancing
some of the people would strip their
clothes off they would start howling
like animals they would start having sex
with each other well there you go
right so they were just they glitched
out and they just went back to like an
atavistic
like an animalistic type of reaction the
same way that a rebellion yeah that that
an animal would react when put under
those same City right then it's all
deniable
I wasn't rebelling it was a curse yeah
it was like it was a demon beasts or
something like that right so like I said
in the modern era once that happened
nowadays I think that's probably more a
sense of you know oh it was a virus or
it was a poison gas or something like
that because again that's another way of
letting out your stresses when you can't
otherwise right right but attributing it
to an outsider so it's not me it wasn't
my fault
right you know that I acted in that
particular way damn that sounds like
poltergeist that's what I mean it
there's kind of an overlap yeah you know
it's a similar type of thing like I said
you get stressed out people start
glitching out and start acting in a way
you know the only way that they know how
that they can react to that sort of
thing but um but yeah so they're
probably having visions too they think
probably they were there probably
hallucinating yeah you know like I said
it revelations yeah yeah it's almost
kind like an acid trip yeah right it's
rose like a natural acid trip right is
the human brain can release all it
release all different kinds of
serotonins and things like that you know
what say the DMT yeah you know I think
it's called DMT right I'm not like an
LSD they take it yeah yeah yeah but yeah
that's a similar type of thing and like
I said when I pointed out like [ __ ]
about raves and like that you know this
is something that will it will cause
exhaustion and it will physically stress
your body out but it also causes a sort
of euphoria I think that was their only
escape yeah it might have been and like
I said and like you said they had
plausible deniability afterward if they
survived so like I said there were a
bunch of these in the Middle Ages they
have usually they mostly died out by the
17th century you know by the time they
start to modernize around that's yeah
that's what I was gonna say like right
about the time of the Enlightenment and
something like that when actually
medical you know stuff started to come
more into the fore and people understood
science a bit better you know so it kind
of went away there was it's weird
because in Italy they had a specific
type of dancing mania and it was usually
called tarrant ISM and this the symptoms
were not the same where people were were
dancing uncontrollably but they
we did the cause - spiders or scorpions
dancing the tarantella yeah that's
exactly what it is they thought that
that was the only way to get rid of it
that like that you'd get bitten by a
spider or a scorpion and we would have
to dance to get to get the poison out of
you so it was like you know it
manifested itself the same but the cut
but the perceived cause was different
which I thought was kind of interesting
so that was like a whole that was like a
whole different thing that just Italy
had so let's talk about a couple other
ones just briefly there was one I kind
of have I sort of have these in
chronological order you know more or
less there was also one that took place
and this was kind of like a social
socio-political one this actually took
place in 1688 and it was called the
Irish fright and this was a mass panic
took place in December of 1688 this was
during the Glorious Revolution in
England and this was when King James the
second it was like the last few days of
his regime and he was trying to get out
of the country you know he was trying to
go into exile in France and so there
were these armies with all these
different factions fighting and for some
reason there was a mass panic that Irish
soldiers were just going all around
England just massacring people and just
like burning down the villages and just
all this other [ __ ] and they were just
traveling around doing all that those
damn Irish I know and it was funny
because it was really widespread and it
was just kind of like you know there'd
be a town in England so the Irish are
coming my god it's like they're just the
next town away and it went on for quite
a while and it was completely [ __ ]
yeah one person died and it didn't even
have anything to do with Irish people
coming in or anything like monkey people
it was it was just like it's it's crazy
how I mean particularly back then and
maybe it's even worse now because like
the way mass mate is just everywhere
because we all the internet and stuff I
mean back then you just had to rely on
somebody running in town to be like
there you know I mean so it's just kind
of like that but I thought that was
really interesting the dish there was
just there was absolutely nothing to it
there was no wires or mccumbee there was
nothing it was just just a mass paint it
was just a mass panic that have in it
and it burned itself out fairly quickly
for whatever reason I'm not
but like I said one dude died and it
didn't really have anything to do with
anything
kind of sucked because it was a lot of
you know anti-catholic Sam I think I
mentioned before [ __ ] about women and
none nunneries there was a lot of mass
panic so you know more concentrated mass
panics happened and those like I said
the most famous one in France where the
woman started meowing like a cat then
all the other ones did but similar kind
of thing where they would in that case
they would usually say it was like demon
possession and stuff if they started
like swearing or acting out or whenever
you talk about these religious people
having mass pax it always reminds me of
some of those things that I read in that
mysteries of the unexplained book that I
bought where people would be somewhere
in Mexico and they would swear to God
that a group of a thousand people that
the Sun was flashing and that they saw
you know on the top of the church Jesus
appeared and evidently like yeah
thousands of people would see this yeah
I read a little bit about that one
actually there's been a couple of those
yeah and I don't know if if those crowds
ever existed or if somebody just wrote
that thousands of people saw that that
the Sun was flashing and moved all
around and although the power of
suggestion is pretty strong it's like I
imagine if you got a group of particular
people that were particularly prone to
believe in that type of thing you got
them all together and like got him hyped
up enough especially if he got him hyped
up and they haven't made him look at
this you could make him see some [ __ ]
that wasn't there maybe they were
looking at the Sun too long and a [ __ ]
was flashing just because they were they
were looking at it I don't know yeah
yeah that could totally happen and then
they look at the church and they think
they see Jesus on top because their
eyeballs yeah they're probably seeing
all kind of did that happen or somebody
just did something just right that that
happened that's what I never really know
I know you know I really can't tell yeah
and honestly at this stage particularly
stuff too long ago and it was too long
ago there's no way of knowing because
like I said how many times have we come
across you know some quote-unquote
paranormal stories a weird story and
then you find out later on that the
earliest instance of it was just like a
fictional story yeah that somebody wrote
joke or somebody heard it as a fictional
like a short story and then somebody
picked it up and ran with it yeah now
suddenly everybody thinks it really
happened yeah like I let it do the
mountain and finding the dinosaurs right
exactly
it didn't happen they just say just
wrote that and it has repeated as if it
is no sometimes people would write
things you know for newspapers and stuff
like that and they were at the time they
were understood to be satirical yeah but
over the years as our senses of humor
changed and you know our writing style
changed we don't recognize it as satire
anymore so we take it as though already
really reported that I read that
pterodactyl story you know the guys
making the joke that's what I was
thinking about the pterodactyl they
found a stalactite and when they touched
it it broke off and I realized it was
just it was a dried-up pterodactyl
they're trying to flap its wings and
leave and then it died when I hit the
sunlight it started to fall apart and I
read that as a you know the 15 16 years
old and I thought that they had really
happened for many years and I was like
man yes I guess there are some ways
where a you know a pterodactyl could be
slightly preserved you know anything but
it turned out and because it says in the
story is witnessed by hundreds of people
but you can write that in you can write
it you can write anything million people
aside you know everybody saw the [ __ ]
well yeah battle that story you you
telling me that story was noble
inspiration for yeah it was hard to find
the original source for that but I
originally I found the original so kind
of walked around thought I think that
was it well they don't know about it was
a satire yeah they don't know about this
but no they did find a pterodactyl all
right so I have like a bunch more cases
that I want to talk about but it's
getting you know a little past the
halfway point so let's take a break at
the moment we'll all run around and go
make a sandwich or whatever's you want
to do and we'll be back in a few minutes
and talk about some more cases of mass
hysteria
[Music]
okay everybody Ginny's got some new
shirts designs up four of them really
good ones to Atlanta Ripper who put
Bella in the wit out the HH Holmes
murder castle and of course demon child
cuz man said he could these are updated
designs I think they look really cool
Jenny did a great job
bottom where they found making Jenny
they were very fun and thank you very
much I think they came out right yeah
they really good they're very high
quality shirts Jenny and I we're sure
our own shirts at certain times when
we're trying to put a spotlight on
ourselves and you can put a spotlight on
yourselves if you go ahead and pick up
on these shirts today you guys are gonna
love them mix in the description WWL
calm at 13 o'clock yes ago check out our
store at wwl calm slash 13 o'clock we
got these four cool new t-shirt designs
plus all our old ones if you'd rather
get one of the old ones but these ones
are awesome and you should check them
out they're also available in women's
cotton they look really cute
JT's got some so thank you go check them
out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay we're back talking about cases of
mass hysteria
throughout history now there was another
spate of sort of localized mass hysteria
outbreaks during the Industrial
Revolution and a little bit further past
when people were kind of crammed
together in factories and you know
didn't have a lot of Rights didn't have
a lot of vacation time or anything like
that so there was a lot of them that
happened in that in that kind of
situation also these mostly happened
across Europe and the United States also
in Singapore a little bit there were
actually six outbreaks of them in
Singapore factories this was actually in
the 1970s and a lot of the workers
started displaying really strange you
know psychosomatic I guess you could
call it symptoms they would go into like
trances they would start screaming or
you know acting out like acting
generally violent they would start
feeling like really cold really nam
really dizzy that type of thing the
thing about this and I think
sociologists have said this too that
it's like the more you legitimize these
types of things like in the media or if
they bring somebody in to deal with it
it tends to make it worse because what
they did in these cases of the Singapore
outbreaks in these factories was they
would bring in a medicine man to kind of
alleviate or like exercise and of the
like the genie that they thought was
causing it and that tended to make it
worse because it was like legitimizing
yeah that really existed
so that tended to make it worse so
generally you know and and they kind of
brought this up too during the whole
clown scare and that kind of thing
they're like the more the media is on it
the worse it gets it just reminds me of
my gas leak yeah you think you have a
gas leak in your house you're gonna keep
smelling gas yeah
there's no gas leak in the house right
I've had my I've had it happen
yeah it doesn't like I said it's easy to
do and like I said people are you know
most people are very suggestible and
it's like if somebody just insists then
it's like do you smell that I smell
smoke I smell poison gas you might start
smelling it you might
start smelling it too just because you
know that it's like a survival instinct
really because you know if bad [ __ ] was
gonna happen to the person in the next
cave you need to know about that [ __ ]
right nobody's like I thought I heard a
tiger you better [ __ ] think there's
really a tiger there otherwise your ass
is gonna get eaten so you can see why
that happens it's just in the modern era
it kind of you know a lot of times not
so not so good because a lot of times is
not danger there's no danger it's fine
but you know your body reacts as if
there is there was another kind of
famous when this actually took place in
1962 and this happened in North Carolina
and it was a textile mill that had
predominantly female employees baby
crazy yeah again they call this the June
bug outbreak because all of these women
it ended up being 62 women that were
affected they started having symptoms
that their skin would break out in
rashes and they would start nausea
vomiting that type of thing now they
initially thought that it was an insect
or a bug that was biting them that had
come in on the latest shipment of
fabrics and was biting them and making
them sick now they did actually bring in
you know health officials and things
like that to check because they said you
know that's not crazy that's not like
without the realm of possibility that
could totally happen you know there
could be something going on in here
could be a gas leak could be lots of
things nothing from the die making you
right it could have been that now but
find anything so they kind of classed
this as a case of mass hysteria they did
note that of the 62 people that were
affected 59 of them were women most of
them thought that they had been bitten
by this particular bug that had come in
with the fabric solution it was it was
an insect
you know infestation is what they
thought it was but like I said they
couldn't find any insects they couldn't
really find any organic cause for it but
they did note that most of the women
that were affected were the women that
were most likely to work overtime they
were the women most likely to deny that
they were tired or deny that they had
problems or
anything like that most of them had
children at home that they were raising
most of them were also the main
breadwinners breadwinners for their
families and the main childcare you know
person that would do all the child
stress so they were under a great deal
of stress and again this is not to
preclude like I said they're they're
very well may have been an organic cause
in this particular case it's just that
officials could not find one it may have
been an allergic reaction it's Mandarin
air and that's something that I don't
really think that they would necessarily
find with this type of not back then not
back then because you know that's the
thing it's like it's just kind of like
do you remember that case and I can't
remember where it happened I feel like
it happened and I don't know New York
Pennsylvania something like that with
that woman that came in and she had I
believe it was cervical cancer and they
brought her into the ER oh the woman did
yeah like everybody started passing out
yeah and I think didn't see me die yeah
I think they did actually what I think
one or two the people that were there
dealt with her died she was giving off
some kind of poison and the thing is
it's like at the time that happened
I think they initially thought that that
was a case of mass hysteria because it
was a bunch of nurses in the room and
like not everybody passed out like it
only affected a few you know some of the
people and not everybody's gonna do a
show about obviously yeah but I think in
the end they did find out that there was
an organic cause to her there was a
reason for it or there was like a
plausible reason why I think yeah she
had cancer but I think from what just
just out of memory from what I remember
of it wasn't there some kind of
possibility to certain kinds of
poisonous gases or some kind of a
disease was in her and when they they
cut open her stomach or she's vomited
something up I don't remember and the
gases that could have spread up some
kind of a toxin yeah it was narrow yeah
I think it was some kind of chemical
reaction a weird neurotoxin it killed a
couple people made a bunch of him sick
yeah like I said I don't know if they
actually proved it definitively but I
have seized a hospital that it was a
plausible scenario like why because like
I said initially I think they thought it
was mass hysteria because not everyone
was affected equal remember it was some
kind of it was something kind of weird
like she gave off a chemical that was a
neurotoxin it was it wasn't yeah that's
what yeah I'm pretty wasn't a bacteria
it wasn't a fire
it was some kind of a chemical that was
like a like a nerve agent yeah and her
body had somehow produced it yeah but
yeah similar thing happened this
actually happened in a town like a
university town which is unnamed in the
Midwest somewhere this happened in 1974
again like in in an office environment
or like in a working environment so
there were 39 workers there and 10 of
them started having specific symptoms
dizziness fainting vomiting nausea that
type of thing and they perceived that it
was some kind of gas like they had been
gassed again they brought in the health
officials officials couldn't find
anything so they termed it a caught a
case of mass hysteria again noting that
the ten people that were affected were
all young women they were all putting
their husbands or boyfriends through
college so they were kind of the main
breadwinners at the time and they also
were the ones that hated their job the
most somebody's [ __ ] be crazy but
they helped a man crazy [ __ ] put you
through college and everything right
yeah even though they're [ __ ] they
have to work in some yeah they got a
worker to scratch and have [ __ ]
stress disorders yeah then you go to
college to come back and tell her to
shut up
yeah and she probably named that dishes
she probably knew that on some yeah yeah
she knew that she's like I'm working in
the shitty factory then he gets out of
college and goes cop comes back yeah
having babies yeah and like doing a
clean and all his [ __ ] underwear and
[ __ ] like that it's like that'll be my
life till I die yeah there's like I'm
just gonna pass out and they mean have
they didn't didn't even have a laundry
machine inspector that's right to do
that [ __ ] by hand
well yeah you gotta do everything by
hand like until they had to take all day
to do laundry of course it would yeah
it's like now it's like you know yeah I
hate to do it now it's like you just
throw it in there I don't like folding
it that's what I don't we fold that [ __ ]
together I know baby cookie jumps in the
pile oh my god the hot when it's hot
he's me coming back from the laundry
room she's got laundry she's like oh oh
oh she pours it on the bed she
right in the pile sound like we sound
pitiful and [ __ ] with it with our cat as
a surrogate child and [ __ ] you know I
mean that's like that that's like some
millennial stuff
she's wait Millennials don't have babies
they just have cats but we're not
Millennials we're X or X generation
yeah but cats are better yeah than
babies yeah they're quieter you can
leave them alone further for a time you
know what I mean that they don't need
constant monitoring they're good you
know so cheaper they're a lot cheaper
you'd have to put them through college I
don't come back I get it I get it what I
don't pick on Millennials man I don't
pick on Millennials there's a
evolutionary dead ends that's the
primary generation is the same at every
generation is like these kids today mama
and I always told myself I'm not gonna
be that crotchety old fart
that for the last 2,000 because I think
even [ __ ] Socrates or Plato said some
[ __ ] too about oh these kids today
memorize so it's like going on for
thousands of years it's like know that
no generation is worse than any other
day everybody goes through the same I
think Millennials are evolutionary dead
ends I don't think they'll ever have
kids just like this I've heard the
generations er kind of hardcore though
that they're kind of like x-gen they
were like us now I mean they're you know
there are some generalizations and I
think our true
you know our Gen Xers more cynical and
crabby yeah yeah I found that no not
everybody
we were more free than Millennials um
Millennials believe in rules that don't
matter if you ask me in general did the
help do the [ __ ] you want to do do
whatever the [ __ ] we want as long as
reason as long as what you want to do
isn't like cutting other people's heads
yeah unless they deserve it I'm just
hoping that [ __ ] you all right so now
let's go to 1938 and this was the case
of the Halifax slasher now this was very
similar to the case that we talked about
on one of the other shows that we did
about the mad gasser of Mattoon where
it's like it's possible that one thing
happened but then like the more people
heard about it
the more people were like yeah that guy
he's everywhere you know what it means
that type of thing so it was that kind
of man
Caesarion not like an illness or
anything but so this happened in
November of 1938 now the first woman
well actually it was two women it was a
woman named Mary Gledhill and a woman
named Gertrude watts now they said that
they had been attacked I guess like
slash that was like a knife or a razor
by a guy with um who was holding a
mallet and had quote-unquote bright
buckles on his shoes did this attack
happen for real maybe maybe not
they're not really sure this is the
first one however when that was reported
in the media suddenly everybody was
getting attacked by this dude so they
thought that this guy was just like
going around slashing at people even
though I think like I said they said
mallet but later on it kind of morphed
into like knife or race but nobody got
hurt so yeah and they found like a bad
gasser that's what I said yeah I just
said that but this was very similar than
mad gasser attack which like I said the
the initial you know kind of incident
very well might have happened I mean I
like Springhill gym to spring it Spring
Heeled Jack Jack bring Hill Jack was
pretty good Elvis that was the British
that was the Steampunk Batman yeah yeah
and that's the thing it's like I feel
like in these cases of mass hysteria as
I said that's not to say you know was
there a guy walking around slashing
people I can believe that because look I
write true crime and worse [ __ ] than
that happens every god that was anybody
cut well a couple people were yeah but
they did find out that later on some
people that had scratches had come from
other things one guy did it to himself
it's fishy to me you know [ __ ] like that
so like I said you know did the first
attack happen might have the subsequent
ones they're pretty sure did not so it
was just kind of a case of maybe
something happened and then everybody
just took it crazy out of control off
man yeah well just like the bad gasser
where it's like you know the initial
incident might have happened yeah maybe
some crazy guy like tried to gasp
somebody it's like it weird [ __ ] like
that happens like I said I write true
crime horrible [ __ ] happens all the time
randomly so I'm not discounting the fact
that the
first one might not have happened but
then the subsequent ones after that
everybody said hey yeah that happened to
me too and all this other kind of stuff
so I think that's kind of I think
Springhill Jim I think Springhill Jack
actually did happen though I think there
was somebody some steam punk kid figured
out parkour it sounds like something a
guy in his late teens early 20s would do
that does sound like so much I mean yeah
yeah yeah although it might end up
biting you in the ass because I think
that does happen because I think in this
case the problem was that this panic
like I said it was in the town of
Halifax was in England it kind of got so
out of hand that mobs were like finding
people in Surrey combed he's the slasher
yeah
now some people did get arrested but
they got arrested for like falsifying
reports and things like that like after
this holds it cuz the whole thing only
lasted about a week or two and then the
newspaper finally came out and said
there's no slasher everybody calm down
it's like it wasn't there it's like a
bunch of the [ __ ] was just so settled
down so and then it just kind of
deflated but yeah so I also want to talk
a little bit about now I have to mention
the quote/unquote were the world's panic
with Orson Welles and it's radio show
and everything like that yeah it's
pretty much established that the whole
Oh everybody was like freaking out and
thinking it was really Martians and like
running from their homes and arming
themselves and stuff that was wildly
exact really exaggerated wildly
exaggerated and the newspapers uh
exaggerated it to just to sell copies
yeah because it was good press you know
what I mean yeah the newspapers made it
seem like it was a panic made it seem
like it was a big panic now did some
people like actually think it was real
for a short time they do think yeah that
some people did think it was really
happening but then as they listened to
it they were just kind of like oh I
gotcha
I mean they did make it sound like a
real news report it was a reality read
but the thing is it's like they had said
at the beginning of the show that it was
a show it was a show there was
radio show there was some of the stuff
is happening so quickly how could you
think that I mean like that okay and we
return to our normal broadcasting
there's like 10 seconds of a song and
then it comes back in there on the other
side of the planet yeah the other side
unites oh and the walking machines are
coming and look at that people are
running in the laser beam and they're
burning up it's fire oh the humanity oh
yeah so like I said I thought I just
thought I had to mention that because
that's a case that gets brought up in a
lot of not very well researched Oh cases
of mass hysteria throughout history even
though that was really not for real a
hysteria like not it even if some people
read briefly did believe it was real it
was wild that [ __ ] launched Orson Welles
- the [ __ ] stars he was been behind
some of that [ __ ] yeah that's totally
viral I think he encouraged a lot of
that because then he came out all me
yeah I know I should just so good you
guys believed it you know and then the
next again now you know he's like a huge
star can you can you think like as an
artist can you think how awesome how
awesome that would be the way think that
my [ __ ] is so good Welles knew how to
play that [ __ ] I feel kind of bad like
especially if people got hurt or
something that did but deep down you'd
be going yes unbeknownst to most people
you know evidently if I go Welles
evidently had quite a way with the
ladies
I think everybody's way with the ladies
they say that if he walked into the any
of those Hollywood clubs this is like
back in the golden era you know I mean a
[ __ ] Hollywood back when Hollywood
was [ __ ] awesome they said he would
walk into some of those bars right and
it was just wow women yeah you know he
was a chick Matt chick magnet he's just
a little little big guy you know what
though I have to say cuz um I have some
pictures of him and I was like looking
for some that I was gonna put in the
video cuz I knew I was gonna talk about
this a little bit he was a good-looking
fella back in today I mean when he got
fat he had power well it's that voice
yeah he has such a great carry gravitas
he it's like a really good he has a lot
of charisma and but like I said yeah he
was a good-looking dude back Nixon yeah
man who saw tomorrow that movie they'd
played that thing on rotation bringing
fire down on the new city its Orson well
so you bought it oh yeah that shit's
gonna happen it's gonna happen
ooh now that was like oh I just thought
of something it's like Orson Welles said
it I believe it maybe that's why they
had him do that because they said oh
people will believe it if you say cuz
they did that worth world [ __ ] yeah of
course
Oh believe anything there is no why for
it's time to show you some cheap
California wine this is fancy as [ __ ]
right yeah you have to be our generation
understanding there had these whole
series of commercials that was geht was
it was Gallo [ __ ]
martini and Rossi was it no no no and
they had these commercials on television
for with this why'd I just read a little
California and Orson Welles is so slick
he sell you this wine it was like it was
some fine [ __ ] from France and it was
like a hundred years old no it was like
from last month made up and [ __ ] San
Bernadino yeah I mean and you know it
was it wasn't expensive it was cheap
[ __ ] those guys okay though it's
perfectly serviceable I'm not I don't
know hardly anything about wine I don't
know I do think that a lot of the [ __ ]
about wine though is just California
want is hype and it's funny is this is
in those days kept the California wine
was all grown by Japanese farmers yeah
because in fact back right before the
Second World War
California got inundated by Japanese
immigrants in that data so they did it
set those great fields made wine and
they give them all these Italian names
and [ __ ] it's bad martini and Rossi and
Asti Spumante guys making that [ __ ] yeah
like I said it's all about the packaging
you just
packed wines we have French or Italian
or what is Japanese California wine yeah
it's like if you gave wine well nowadays
you could do it but back then if you
gave wine a Japanese name people be like
what the [ __ ] yeah yeah back in those
days it made in Japan it was cheap yeah
it was all about the that'd be like
saying meeting Pakistan yeah somebody so
let's uh since we're talking kind of
about War of the Worlds too let's talk
about the first wave of flying saucer
sightings now this is interesting
because this happened in 1947 in the
whole pretty much the whole perception
of UFOs as quote-unquote flying saucers
comes from one dude and this dude was
Kenneth Arnold yeah kenan june 1947 was
flying his little plane in washington
state near the Cascade Mountains when he
saw what he reported as nine glittering
objects yeah flying in like a formation
yeah near Mount Ranier
yeah now he didn't specifically did not
say didn't say it looked like saucer no
I said they look like flying V's he said
that their movement was like a saucer
skipping of water that's what he said
that the movement was like that even say
that they looked like saucers yeah
however when the media reported it they
reported quote-unquote flying saucers
and not surprisingly after this story
ran in 1947 suddenly everybody that's
all UFO said it looked like a flying
saucer
even though there had really been no
there had been like isolated reports of
like seeing a saucer like that's good
they're only like a couple but after
1947 when that story came out suddenly
every single UFO so they look like
crescent moons or maybe like a Flying V
which that's that that makes a lot of
sense and honestly at the time he did
not think he reported it because he
thought it was like enemy aircraft yeah
I didn't think it was a couple
explanations for that they may have been
testing the same prototypes or the Sabre
jet yeah in that area the Sabre Jets
kind of had a swept wing design and
maybe from a distance if the light was
hitting at the right way you wouldn't
you see the fuselage you just see those
swept-back wings
which was unusual for that time and
maybe just may have kind of looked a
little bit like uh like a moon crescent
shape from a distance another thing is
is that they were flying wing aircraft
at this time you know the Germans had a
flaw of the Horten I think it the
Whorton x19 I think is what it was
called and it was a swept wing kind of
Flying V jet yeah and we had it we had
stolen it from the captured it from the
Germans and we had it back here in the
United States now in the Smithsonian
maybe we made a quick copy of a flying
her fee that's complying jet it was
they're not that hard to make yeah okay
the United States had [ __ ] tons of money
and really good designers and lots of
Labor
you know Lockheed Martin we could have
made you know a dozen of those things
just in a matter of months to test them
you know you can make a back of those
days you could make a jet quick yeah not
like today where you have a contract
takes ten years to bring the ship to
fruition they'd make a new brand new
aircraft in a matter of a months you
know back in those days I think maybe he
saw some kind of test craft yeah
although I'm a lean more towards
something kind of like the Sabre jet
yeah you know what I mean not so not
probably not a flying wing because our
guys knew about flying wings you know
Jack Northrop was making them and Benham
Jack Northrop design you know and like I
said it should be noted too that this
particular guy like I said he didn't
report it as space aliens or not though
he thought it was autocrat enemy
aircraft or something like that so he
better report it also he was not
military civilian I think he had
military experience though didn't he uh
he might have maybe he did he just saw
something unusual in the sky maybe you'd
report it right you just saw something
unusual craft I think there were
probably some kind of test craft jets we
saw I think it's kind of this is kind of
a similar situation to where people
suddenly started seeing big headed big
eyed gray aliens after that TV movie
that everybody saw that came out in like
1950 whatever it was you know what I
mean before that like descriptions of
aliens were like all over the place but
after that it kind of codified into
doesn't mean that there are no flying
saucers though because later on both the
it's in the soviet-made things that were
disc-shaped yeah you know I mean we made
a little like a hovercraft fake Jeep
there's films of this famous thing John
it didn't really work that well yeah the
the Soviets were working with another
thing that was kind of a wingless
aircraft that you could kind of say it
was a font of a flying saucer it was
kind of stubby for a flying saucer was
kind of tall and fat looking thing but
it didn't really have a wing it was a
lifting body and it was also if I
remember correctly and fibia cyou could
land it on water and take off from water
and it was a weird lifting body thing if
you stand it was from the 60s if you saw
that flying through this guy or a
prototype of that flight this guy and
you didn't know what you were looking at
you'd go yeah that's that's something
from another [ __ ] planet because back
in those days yeah if you're just some
person like I mean even you can go into
the 50s you know the average person may
not really well I guess by the 50s they
knew what a jet was yeah but late
forties know the average person really
wasn't sure what a jet was they expected
all aircraft to have propellers and it
look like a straight wings on it you
know the swept-back wings would have
been impressive you know DeltaWing you
know and like you said when you're
seeing something unexpected your memory
yeah I saw jet when I was it op3 11
actually no I was at South camp at that
time in Egypt the US Army and watched an
Egyptian craft aircraft come in for a
landing because my guard tower was
watching their airport and it happened
so fast man I thought it was some kind
of exotic military jet they asked me to
describe it and I just said man I can't
describe it I think it would look like a
Learjet kind of like camouflage we got
to get in there and look at it was
something military and I saw it for a
good 5 6 7 seconds but I just couldn't I
couldn't remember exactly what it looked
like it just it startled me
so we get hopped in the vehicle went
down and looked at it it was a c-130
painted orange yep
paint an orange c-130 well that's the
thing I was talking to somebody on
YouTube it's very thing where it's like
sometimes like we see movies like back
in the 70s and 80s and remember
particular scenes and then that happened
or remember like liking something not
liking it then you see it later and it's
like completely different than what you
remembered memory is not accurate I
think Kenneth Arnold saw some Jets
that's all about Saul I think you
probably saw some Jets from a distance
they were flying funny yeah in formation
yeah and he just thought he'd reported
cuz ya know what they were it's like
well this might be bad it might be enemy
aircraft Air Force jets alright so the
next one who said a lot of people have
heard about this one the very famous
Tanganyika laughter epic epidemic of
1962 now this started out the nation is
obviously called Tanzania nowadays but
it actually started out in one school in
January of 1962 it was a mission it was
a mission boarding school for girls and
these three girls for whatever reason I
don't know if they told a joke and that
[ __ ] was really funny and they all
started laughing and then it eventually
started spreading throughout the school
now over you know the ensuing days it
started affecting it affected almost a
hundred of 159 girls at this school like
everybody started laughing
uncontrollably I think they had some
other symptoms too like fainting you
know dizziness flatulence
I don't know how uncommon that was but
that was something that I saw imagined
that was like it would they know were
there but yeah so all the girls were
between 12 and 18 years old it was like
a mission run like a high school so
these scrubs was just like laughs for
hours at a time or sometimes days at a
time
and then it started spreading outward
like to other towns and other schools
because some of the girls that went to
this school like lived in another town
so when they went back home and we're
still laughing so then it started
affecting other people in the village
and it eventually spread outward until
it was affecting students at 14 schools
now the first school where this started
they had to shut it down because they're
like the girls are just they're just
laughing and acting crazy and like some
of them were like we're breaking out in
crying is there be crying and stuff like
that and they couldn't
no one could concentrate what year was
this again
1962 Tanzania yeah well developing
country well yeah that's one of the
things that they usually say this
actually like I said this ended up
affecting about a thousand people over
this particular area now what they think
may be the underlying cause of it was
again probably stress induced because
Tanganyika at the time had just won
independence they were their home lives
were still very very conservative very
regimented but the schools were starting
to open out open up more like teaching
them kind of more progressive values and
things like that so there was kind of
that conflict going on like within their
own minds also the education started to
get more not necessarily stringent but
they had higher expectations of the
girls you know they were trying to get
them to learn right trying to well yeah
what they were trying to you know get
higher grades out of them and things
like that so they think that all of
these things kind of happen in in tandem
sort of cause these girls to react in
cause conflict right so they think that
was probably one of the underlying
causes at that but it went on for quite
a long time it went on for months and
months you know in various towns and
various schools until it finally burned
out similar thing happened at another
girls school this happened in Blackburn
England in October of 1965 and this
happened same kind of thing like a
couple girls started complaining they
were dizzy they started passing out you
know there were only a few of them at
first but then about 85 90 girls were
affected in the end now they were
actually taken to the hospital cuz they
thought something was legit wrong with
them like you know there was some kind
of gas leak or something like that
because all these girls just started
passing out some of them had other
things like they'd start moaning or
their teeth would start shattering
uncontrollably [ __ ] like that
so they go to find out what the cause of
it might be if there was some kind of
physical cause and they couldn't cause
they couldn't find anything like they
couldn't find they thought maybe some
there was a gas leak or there was food
poisoning or something like that and
they couldn't find anything so um and
again this is a type of thing where it
started with the older girls it actually
start with the 14 year olds and then
kind of went
affected the younger one closer to
puberty yeah well that's you plus the
younger ones were like oh well the older
girls are getting it so that's the cool
thing to do like I said not consciously
but you know that's kind of now in this
particular case and this is kind of
unusual they gave all the girls that
were affected they gave them these sort
of like you know personality tests and
things of that nature they said um
almost all the girls affected had quite
high scores in extraversion and also in
neuroticism they said now that's like
some people have the perception that
that's true of all mass hysteria cases
but that is that's not the case in other
words [ __ ] be crazy
yeah but they said in this particular
case it was that did happen like these
girls did test higher in extraversion
they had hot they had more friends more
larger social circle and also tested
higher in neuroticism and those were the
girls affected so they think maybe um
sounds a lot like a witch panic then
yeah well like I said it's the same
mechanism it just manifests itself
different in different times at
different cultures and another one that
happened in England this actually
happened in 1980 now this was called the
Holland well incident and this one has
been featured on a lot of kind of 14
times or like paranormal shows and stuff
like that is kind of like government
cover-up type of [ __ ] now this happened
like I said it was July 1980 and there
were all these kids like coming to
Holland well Showground
they were gonna be it's like a band
competition you know the little marching
bands and stuff so they all get there
about 9 a.m. now a lot of the people
that were there noted you know a lot of
the kids had come from a long way they
were tired they were under a lot of
anxiety because they were gonna be
performing you know if in the
competition and stuff like that so there
was a lot of stress in the area now at
about about an hour and a half after
everybody got there all these kids were
like in the bands just started like
fainting okay
now one witness said just all these kids
started falling down so the quote was
the children were falling down like
ninepins they all just start dropping so
you know they also started throwing up
they started getting sore throats they
starting a dizzy stuff they say have
another people say where it happens oh
yeah they're worried that's gonna happen
to them and what does happen now they
asked one of the girls it was affected
she actually said and this is her quote
my legs and arms felt as if they had no
bones in them yeah and she also
complained about a headache
now this actually ended up affecting 300
people now wasn't just kids which is
something that I find kind of
interesting adults were also affected
also babies were affected well kind of
makes me think maybe there were some
vets might not be mass hysteria because
a baby would not know wouldn't know you
know what I mean so I'm kind of feeling
like maybe the how was a baby affected
no I'm just saying you know same kind of
thing babies got sick or babies Pat I
don't know but they just said babies
were affected also now a bunch of the
people were taken to hospitals nine of
the kids were actually kept overnight
for observation so even though like I
said they kind of went through and says
maybe it's food poisoning maybe this
that the other cuz they do kind of try
to find a physical cause when this
happens cuz sometimes it is I mean you
know sometimes like I said it's a
foodborne illness or nationality yes or
something no no I don't think anybody
complained about that now what they kind
of established like I said later on they
said okay it was mass hysteria we didn't
find anything however a lot of the
people that experienced it think that
and some researchers think that it might
have been a nearby pesticide
particularly this pest afire
pesticide called try to morph now try to
morph had actually been banned in
Britain in 2000 that was like later on
but they do think that there might have
been some pesticide Ascend taining that
that was sprayed nearby
okay the pesticide is basically nerve
agent yes it's just tailored to insects
it's a nerve agent that mammals aren't
affected by nausea vomiting okay
weakness shortness of breath and so I'm
going to lost some muscle muscle control
is the signs of nerve agent poisoning
yeah maybe that might have been yeah
slight nerve agent poisoning from that
yeah but I mean that to me seems kind of
plausible yeah like I said the fact that
they did say that like babies were also
affected it makes me think that maybe
although like I said officials really
some insecticides that have been banned
kinda had slight nerve agent effects
which is why they ban so but yes like I
said good be could be that you might
have it this pesticide was actually
banned later on this happened in 1980 it
was banned in 2000 yeah so there is
speculation that this might not be Massa
Cerie that there was actually the best
aside that contained this that contained
this particular pesticide and it
actually you know affected some of the
people at this particular show going so
that one you know I had to mention it
because it comes up a lot on paranormal
stuff but I'm kind of leaning toward
maybe that was like a good beer like a
poison gas now let's talk a little bit
about I want to talk about the clown
sightings that I want to talk about the
penis do not want your penis to
disappear so yeah so the most recent
case about okay the clown sightings and
this was like a big thing and it's kind
of reached its apex in 2016 but it
actually kind of had a few things like
before that now the interesting thing
about the clown panic is that this isn't
such a crazy thing because it's very
easy for some Joker somewhere it'll like
put on a clown suit and lurk around or
like people I already know what this is
and you know what I mean so that's a
very easy thing to happen so it's not
like you're talking about some you know
mystery slasher that's not really exists
I mean obviously you can just buy a
clown suit and jump on people you know
what I mean there's videos of this
though there's photographs of people
doing this right I know what this is
well and like I said the more the media
fueled it and hyped it the more the more
people are gonna be like oh well
wouldn't it read a strong case to put on
so okay but the thing is even though
like I said it reached its apex in 2016
but everybody's like killer clowns
they're all police you know what I mean
there were actually a few kind of proto
cases now going back to 2013 probably
the highest profile one was actually
three filmmakers in Nottingham England
and they actually started like kind of
as a viral marketing type of thing they
said we're gonna start a Facebook page
called the Nottingham clown or a creepy
clown or whatever
you know kind of based on Pennywise so
they had somebody dressed in like a
penny wise II look in clown suit and he
would stand in like kind of incongruous
places like looking very menacing and
they would take pictures of it and they
would put it on their Facebook page like
I said it was like a fun like a viral
marketing thing so that kind of took off
and then there was a guy in Italy who
had a YouTube channel called DM pranks
and this was also starting about 2014
and he would put on like a scary-looking
clown suit and he would go like jump on
people like jump out and be like brah
and then like scare Ben that he would
film their reactions and then he would
put it on his YouTube channel and his
YouTube channel got millions and
millions of views so I think that by the
time 2016 rolled around people were like
primed to be like [ __ ] creepy clap
I'm gonna say it goes even before that
well yeah late 90s and in the 2000s
there was a Detroit band called ICP
insane clown posse everybody knows
everybody knows it shaggy - dope violent
Jay and you know what they were [ __ ]
hilarious kind of talented but a very
strange rap bad and a lot of the lyrics
I had several of their albums like a toy
box and you know I forgotten their first
one was [ __ ] I forgot it's been so long
sit but the lyrics in an ICP record
encourage you to be what's called a
Juggalo which a Juggalo is kind of like
a punk rocker but it's a rap version of
it and you have clown like aspects and
you run around throw Faygo on people
scare the [ __ ] out of people get your
ass kicked
yeah as you would you know that's all in
there you know I mean did some of this
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah it's not it
Juggalos are kind of like losers in a
way yeah they're like losers in a way
they're clowns you know and and they're
owning it yeah you know so some of this
stuff sounds like Juggalo sightings yeah
it's not my jugular would do
a Juggalo would do something like dress
up like this crazy clown and jump out
and scare some black kids in the hood
that's exactly what a judge because this
is you know ICP was a was a detroit band
it was just hood as [ __ ] even though
they were white guys it just there's a
lot of weird inconsistencies in ICP
you know but it's just but that was part
of the joke yeah yeah you had the whole
ICP thing yeah could have been many
factors at wants the Juggalos would go
do this [ __ ] I saw Juggalos in the
French Quarter New Orleans yeah okay and
when and when I said and when I said
Juggalos and I was dressed up as a goth
kid they [ __ ] flipped out because I
knew what a Juggalo was and this is back
in late 90s when people didn't notice me
let me rap with you yeah yeah yeah
they're like ah you know they had the
clown makeup on there that punk rockers
the clown makeup I would like to address
you Jeff yeah yeah step aside I'm here
to address the juggling yeah yeah yeah I
would like I seek an audience with the
like and they were doing what Juggalos
did they [ __ ] had drinking in public
what the you know and out of paper bags
it's [ __ ] crazy
don't worry about so it's kind of
licking like clouds and losers yeah like
what does that world-famous clown
bum-bum-bum fighting no no no no Moses
no is it that really famous clown what
the [ __ ] was named Emmett Kelly Emmett
Kelly oh he was like a drunk like yeah
yeah yeah like that that's going way
back but yeah so so you had like I said
you had insane clown posse you also had
the nottingham clown which was kind of a
thing like i said it was a viral
marketing thing you kind of had the damn
pranks you know the youtube channel so
there was kind of that going on but then
like the kind of clown panic that
happened in 2016 actually originated in
South Carolina and this little
nine-year-old boy reported that two guys
in clown suits had like tried to get him
to come into the woods with them so
whether these two guys existed or not I
mean
like I said that's not crazy [ __ ] like
some black a the time no I don't know it
probably was
okay I'd heard that I saw a local
television report and I can't make it
was I think it was Louisiana saying that
South Carolina okay I think but I'm
saying I saw one personally that was
happening in Louisiana this is back in
the early 2000s where young black kids
were reporting that they were seeing
clowns okay and that clowns were coming
out behind the dumpsters and that with
video cameras and the kids were running
off and the police were warning whoever
it is it's doing this just to knock it
off which of course is because they're
they're gonna get shot for doing that
because I kind of feel like a lot of
them were probably panic and I'm not
saying like I said I'm not saying that
some of them weren't real because
obviously they were because like I said
how easy is it just put on the clown
suit and like lurk around it scary but
like I said you're yeah and they weren't
picking on black kids you're gonna get
your ass they weren't picking on black
kids because racial reason is because
Juggalos and the whole Juggalo identity
from ICP was being a white guy in a
black hood that was the that's the
that's that's where that band is coming
from yeah so that's where they would go
but the thing is because they get beat
up yeah that was the idea it was like
masochism yeah that's all about to get
beat up well I think I get the lesson I
think Viola Jed Shaggy 2 dope you know I
mean they were white guys in the hood
they got beat up a lot they dressed up
like cops so their fans were trying to
emulate that yeah it's [ __ ] crazy so
anyway like don't try to make sense out
of Juggalos but evidently so so the
whole the height of the clown panic that
happened in 2016 was actually stemmed
from this one case in South Carolina
where this kid said hey you know there
was these two guys dressed like clowns
and they were trying to get me to come
in the woods with them and from that
from these seeds it subsequently went on
since pretty much every state in the
Union started reporting
the clowns clowns clowns went all over
Europe South America everywhere Russia
Eastern Europe everywhere so everywhere
is starting to see people in [ __ ]
clown suits like I said were those some
of these legitimate sure yeah you know
how easy would it be but it got so bad
that some states I think Ohio was one of
them there were probably another ones in
some countries we're pretty much like
okay can we not like sell clown masks
for a little while can we not sell clown
outfits
I think target even pulled all of its
like clown masks and stuff like out off
their website like for a time this was
going on my explanation is Juggalos and
Juggalo copycats
yeah Juggalos i [ __ ] of Juggalos
started that [ __ ] and people started
copying it and if you probably trace it
yet you could probably chase it back to
somebody like violent J telling Juggalos
to do it yeah it's probably what
happened but yeah it's pretty sad and
the thing about this like I said and
this this just goes to show how cases of
mass panic mass hysteria can like affect
people's lives affect people's
livelihoods you know the [ __ ] got so bad
that people who make their living as
clowns either in circuses or you know
you doing birthday parties and stuff
like that they were like losing
significant business because suddenly
everyone's afraid of clowns clowns are
like evil killers so it really kind of
affected their money and they were like
the guys like one of the guys it was
like the head of like the clown
Association or whatever like in the US
was like coming out going unite you guys
like knock it off you're making us all
look bad we're losing money because of
you and all this other kind of [ __ ] it's
like it kind of makes me laugh because
that [ __ ] no way hey like some people
like clowns I'm not hating it's like I'd
say I don't have any like feelings for
against it's like clowns it's some
people think that's some cries people
says I don't really think about it all
that much but I kind of laughed because
the times are scary well yeah a lot of
people do think bands are scary like I
can see why I mean it's just like
somebody going around the man you don't
know what they really look like they
have like a fake exact last that last
horror movie that we saw was pretty
[ __ ] cool with that era fire
yeah with the clown yeah like people
always have always been the clowns are
scared soon as John Wayne Gacy hit the
scene that was that was a wrap for the
clouds if you ask me yes maybe we should
be blaming him he ruined it for
everybody yeah but no I kind of laughed
because the Wikipedia page when it's
talking about you know how circuses and
stuff were affected I love that it says
circuses and other clown related
businesses it's like I want to start a
band called clown related business
circuses were on their way out anyway
well they even say the animals they even
said like big companies like McDonald's
they're like we had to like in their
advertising they're like we had to tone
down the Ronald McDonald thing because
everybody freaking out of clowns
so it's like that all their ad they had
to pull them at all their advertising
and [ __ ] like that they're ugly well
yeah they can be sure you know the only
clowns that I didn't think we're ugly
was a damn French heart than French
Carla Quinn yeah and that's like it that
seems like a difference that's like a
different thing but Dave I guess because
it's a cultural difference yeah that
seems like a very stylish carnival
looking kind of almost like a mime no
mimes are not annoying anyway but but
they're not scary you're not scary
though no I'm not sure why maybe because
you can still see their facial
expressions it's just white
I mean clowns they like usually that the
big painted smile this Harlequin of all
times with David Bowie from the scary
monsters album he was ya ashes to ashes
video just a second
Harlequin yeah but it should be said so
most of the clown sightings were you
know were just like mass panic now it
should be noted though that there was
before Halloween of 2016 there was like
a lot of chatter that there was going to
be some some massive like nationwide
clown and purge style attacks on people
on Halloween
even then obviously that did not happen
except in guess where [ __ ] Florida
yeah there was one attack in Florida
where a group of 20 people dressed as
clowns or also with those purge style
masks on with the lights and [ __ ] they
actually attacked a family they didn't
kill them but you know they kind of like
attacked them and like assaulted them
and stuff don't ask [ __ ] kids
yeah because you get your ass shot off
in Florida that's what I mean
you're lucky you picked one it wasn't
packing yeah like I said seriously do
not dress up like a clown and you attack
a family like that and that dudes
[ __ ] packing heat you attacking a
bunch of masa he kills three or four
dudes you gonna walk he's gonna walk
that's justification well of course yeah
you got attack no no jury would would
would convict no they wouldn't are you
trash yeah
all right so last thing I wanna talk
about let's talk about because I know
how much you guys have been looking
forward to this yeah yeah yeah yeah
penis as I looked into this like I said
it's not always penis thieves that's
that's a particularly African
manifestation of it um actually this
stealing a brother's prized possession
man as well no this is this is actually
considered what they call a
culture-bound syndrome yeah in that even
though there are isolated cases of it in
the US and they're isolated case em in
the US and even though it is a
legitimate psychological thing it's it's
a type of body dysmorphia um but it's
generally more prevalent in cultures
where where fertility and having
children is very valued that's kind of
like your main value as a person and big
dick culture well no yeah like I said it
actually the name of it Koro that
actually is from China because that's
the highest prevalence of it is in China
Oh then like I said it happened all over
the world that's all of it where idea
but when it when it manifests itself is
like a mass hysteria it usually had I
saw I saw this most recited on this most
recent case of in Africa and I was just
like [ __ ] tripping what they accused
this accused this dude have taken again
another guy's dick yeah killed him over
it and then they cook and then they
looked at the dude who made the
accusation and he had a dick they said
well yeah it doesn't make any sense
like I said it's a sort of body
dysmorphia said yeah it's just kind of
like thought the other good dude took
his dick yeah it's kind of like when you
have an erection you feel like that even
though you weigh 80 pounds or you know
it's kind of a thing where people think
their hands are too big or something
because that is a thing
yeah so it's a it's a type of body
dysmorphia disorder now when it goes
into mass hysteria like I said they
considered a culture-bound syndrome most
of the early cases of it now there were
cases of it in medieval Europe quite
there were quite a lot of cases of it
then in that case it was always almost
always attributed to witchcraft
obviously cause which I was gonna come
and steal your penis that was your
sexual power so there was a lot of that
going on in the Middle Ages um basically
what this is like I said they call it
Koro or they call it a genital
retraction syndrome it's not so much
that your penis is gone sometimes it is
like someone has taken it but usually
it's like it either it's shrinking or
it's like we're tracting back into your
body now evidently this can really
happen so they do actually have to check
you for retraction I don't he's like
over there
I knew that whatever that was so
evidently Cara Lee I said then you have
to check you make sure your genitals are
not actually retracting back into your
body cavity because it's rare but it
can't happen
but in most of these cases it is a
psychological disorder like I said I saw
the videos of it they got a video
somewhere and over over in when it's
little African cities okay cuz a dude
laying face down on the ground they hung
him he's just dead you know this poor
guy and I'm a mass of people hunted
hunted him down and lynched him and
killed him when the authorities came but
showed up says why'd you kill this guy
they said well he stole that guy's dick
yeah so they interview this guy and they
got this and and they said what happened
and I don't remember it was there was
some kind of a they were selling
something of some caves thing he was a
merchant there was some kind of business
went down between the two and a fight
broke out insults and evidently this guy
thought that the other guy put a curse
on him and took his dick yeah it's a he
see he called all his vices hey this guy
took my dick and they [ __ ] stand up
for your Bros when they started him down
and put him kill it killed him that's
crazy so the authorities are let's see
we'll drop your drawers they drought is
yours and you guys get
right there are we talking about he's
like he took my dick
that's a replacement yeah that just
looking blow my mind man blowing my
[ __ ] mind man yeah but like I said
it's body dysmorphia it is it's somebody
seeing something that's not they're
perceiving something that is a reality
your brain can [ __ ] with you in a lot
you can't [ __ ] trick me to think I
don't have a dick though I don't
understand it man I can't in some kind
of laboratory setting no you're not
gonna be able to say that God helmet
thing on you and legs yes yeah cuz they
can make you think you have like that
your arm is not your arm and [ __ ] like
that if I was somewhere and some dishes
by the way you know he starts fighting
me goes oh by the way I just took you I
just took your dick and man I wouldn't
believe that yeah well it does happen
more often when people have that
particular fear that's why that's why a
lot of the mass hysteria cases of Koro
are usually confined to a specific area
of China where there is a particular
superstition about about people taking
your dickard or someone shrinking your
dick and also the the particular people
that it strikes are usually not only
very superstitious but they don't have
like any good sex education they don't
know you know they think a dick can be
shrunk just by words alone right and and
they don't really understand that like
sometimes if you jump in cold water yeah
it's gonna shrink you know what I mean
they don't understand that that's normal
so it's it's that kind of thing it's
usually like lack of education mixed
with superstition like I said it was the
same thing that happened in the Middle
Ages in Europe when they thought witches
were stealing their penises or shrinking
their penises it was because they didn't
know I mean they didn't know it so
because they had that belief that that's
something that witches did then some
people are gonna buy into that now for a
long time they thought that it was just
like a cultural like a Chinese
phenomenon because like I said this
generally comes from cultures where your
ability to reproduce is kind of like one
of your highest values as a human being
so losing your ability you losing your
dick is a huge fear now the interesting
thing about it is that when it manifests
in China
not only do you have the symptom of oh
my dick is shrinking or oh my dick
disappeared but they also have an
overwhelming fear of death that goes
along with it now it should be noted
that that is a particular manifestation
of the Chinese and like the Asian
manifestation of this when it manifests
itself in other countries it still has
oh my dick is shrinking oh my dick
disappeared or someone took it but it
doesn't have that overwhelming and then
I'm going to die because of it that's a
strict that seems to be a strictly
Chinese addition to that particular
manifestation even though this happens
all over the world it manifests itself a
little bit differently depending on what
the overwhelming like cultural beliefs
are and cultural superstitions are so
it's just it like I said this is a
really interesting thing from a
sociological standpoint cuz I'm always
interested in like culture bouncing
symptoms that scent of syndromes
syndromes um where it's like the same
disorder but there's little tweaks of
difference just because so it just goes
to show how much like how you grew up
where you grew up like the beliefs you
grew up with do kind of affect how
things manifest like even though it's
the same thing it's recognizably the
same disorder but it kind of manifests
itself a little bit different so when it
happens in Africa and there were
actually several mass hysteria about
Koro in Africa in the 1970s and 80s
particularly in Nigeria and stuff like
that just kind of it wasn't like huge it
was just like little outbreaks here and
there so because of their particular
culture beliefs they thought it was
witch doctors or shamans or whatever and
they were stealing your dick and keeping
it somewhere you know what I mean but
they didn't have the whole oh no I'm
gonna die or anything like that and and
the sad thing is because they have that
belief like you mentioned they would
sometimes form like vigilante groups and
go after the perceived witch or
perceived whatever who stole their dicks
and they would kill them because they
really did believe that they were going
around stealing men's dicks so like I
said again this is a case where mass
hysteria can lead to like some really
really bad [ __ ] because it's like here's
this poor guy just sitting in
housed somewhere and like all these
people have you stole my dick he's like
what he's like and they just [ __ ] kill
him so yeah but there were a bunch of
those I think probably the most recent
was in 2008 I think that was in the
Congo but you know similar type of thing
it's just the interesting thing that
what usually makes it go away is sex
education because they're like even in
the cases were at the outbreaks in China
there was some outbreaks in Thailand a
little later on as soon as like you know
the authorities come out and say look
this is what's happening this
superstition isn't true and stuff like
that usually they tend to fizzle out
because people have kind of a better
handle on how but I just I heard this
story is not bad sex education is in
some places of China they had this young
couple have been married for a few years
and they sent the woman to a infertility
clinic because they were trying to have
a kid all right
they couldn't figure out why she wasn't
having a kid right so they [ __ ]
interviewed her and found out that she
wouldn't have the kid because they were
just going anal yeah that's a they
thought that [ __ ] was done do you know
what that's something you know that
fundamentalist Christians like or
there's like a perception that
fundamentalist Christians oh there
aren't allowed to have premarital they
call that the loopholes yeah yeah that's
not just Christian does it count that's
a bunch of different places I like is
that anywhere worth like anywhere where
their virginity is like I think then
yeah that's yeah that's the loophole
yeah which i think is very funny but
yeah but well you know I guess it's like
you're not gonna get pregnant like that
so I guess I guess they knew but you
know yeah yeah you're not gonna get
pregnant with blood stuff understand
yeah but they didn't know that evidently
that's pretty bad it was like see I
thought that was they thought that I
guess you think it would come naturally
if you go there one blade comes out
another you'd think it would come down
train your people it really sex
education people seriously or just the
high quantities of porn might I don't
know I don't think people should be
getting sex education yeah that's true
it says even porn that might be
Azzam unrealistic form for back in the
50s yeah all right so I think this is
probably vanishing penis is everybody
that's what we're gonna look after your
penises guys it's like you never know
when someone's just going to come on
they're gonna steal my dick they better
have a truck with them so anyway I'll do
it for episode 117 have you enjoyed our
long rambling discussion I guess you
guys do you seem to so remember if you'd
like to support the show you can like
share subscribe with all your friends
and family or you can financially
support the show by going to our patreon
page which is patreon.com slash 13
o'clock podcasts or you can go to our
blog which is 13 o'clock podcast
wordpress.com and you can leave a
one-time donation the little link in the
sidebar to a PayPal account if you'd
like to do that also check out our last
movie retrospective which was castle
freak and our last what do you call it
13 o'clock May Day which was Suspiria
Bohemian Rhapsody and the Nutcracker so
check go see Bohemian Rhapsody yeah like
I said don't bother within that cracker
it was very it was alright it was it was
very much it was very mad teenage girls
probably or preteen girls probably liked
it but other than that don't bother
so yeah that'll do it for this episode
so we will see you next time bye
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]